foreign
people welcome to honest trailer
commentaries for John Wick or
post abellum post Bellum oh that would
have been good I thought that was in my
script was it yes I'll have to check
again uh we're gonna uh we're gonna talk
about um
outtakes uh cut jokes talk about the
movie in general and do a q a but I
think that there's like literally nobody
behind the wheel this time Billy would
slacking me I will have to actually be
watching myself on stream oh my God I'll
be watching the Q A's as they come in
don't ask actually don't ask any
questions until I ask for questions and
then I'll look at the chat
um because I don't think anyone else is
here uh so yeah LTZ with next week's
honest trailer
um God just when you think you're out I
never thought I was out on John Wick but
damn I didn't think it could get better
I think this was a action Masterpiece
um I think that I thought it was a good
solid Wick installment until the last
hour when it was like oh I'm so torqued
right now I didn't think I could get
more torqued yeah
um and uh yeah that that final sequence
like all of Paris to the end just
elevated this in a way that I mean there
the the top of their game the top of
their craft I I loved it what do you
guys think oh yeah it was uh I like all
the John Wicks I love like just the all
of the fighting and all of that
um
going back and him talking to all of the
people and then the Betrayal stuff was
all great but yeah I just care about the
face kicking and the ass punching and
that was amazing and then there was like
40 minutes of people falling downstairs
and that was also dope and also my
greatest fear
um
I was picturing Don watching that
sequence like they should really hold on
to the railing go a lot slower
I'll see now you know why I do it um but
yeah just like watching them tumble and
then watching as like the stuntmen you
can see that the momentum was stopping
and so they have to like put their arm
out to continue to go for more kids
catapulting down more stairs good
um yeah the final stuff was great uh
yeah I I really liked it and I liked the
new the Mr Nobody the that new character
that they introduced uh the guy with the
dog I loved that that was very sweet and
obviously like a full circle moment yeah
it was great yeah
we all we all loved the John Wicks but I
do think maybe two especially and a
little bit with three it was getting
bogged down in wicklore yeah a lot of a
lot of table talk a lot of who's above
who's below what you get this marker
yeah and that's still there that's the
Mainstay but it wasn't uh over the top I
think what I like so much about this is
they really do every time there's a new
Wick it doesn't feel like it's just well
let's do more of what we did they they
try to build it it's Gotta It's gotta
get bigger it's got to get crazier the
task in front of him has to get more
challenging each time and so I think
what's so satisfying about this one is
yeah two and three spent so much time
building up this bureaucracy and the
international nature of the table and
and this movie is just well
John's already sort of passed them at
this point like this movie opens with
him in the desert tracking down the
remaining leaders of the table on
Horseback and just like taking them out
like pre-credits basically but like he
was the El so we're gonna get bogged
down already he's the Elder who sits
above the table but I still think we
have not met the table have we been to
the table is it Jada no no no no no we
we've met many many people who sit at
the high table the idea is the high
table is like it's think of it like the
heads of the five families it's just the
leadership of all of these different
criminal organizations with the Elder as
the the centerpiece the like Michael
Corleone figure or whatever so like the
leader of the Russian gang that John's a
member of would sit at the height table
so all those people are high table
members we've never been to a meeting
though no I don't think I think they're
probably saving that in their pocket
like how you don't get to the Specter
meeting until the last Bond film you got
you gotta you gotta wait to the high
table all right uh let's watch the
honest trailer for John mc4 we'll have
more to say as it goes
[Music]
in a world where every franchise has at
least one dud never leave the cave
without John Wick will once again pull
off the impossible and an excellent
fourth film so if it wasn't clear by now
we're never gonna let this franchise
stop have you given any thought
wear this hands nope Kiana's gonna be 80
and we'll watch him snap next in a
tactical diaper
John Wick chapter four
chapter three
it's it's Lionsgate they can't afford to
not make more of these I mean I think
that's what's so like it's it's not that
we want to see John Wick go away but
it's also like literally the entire
Studio Lionsgate is just this in Hunger
Games and then those power shows on
Stars yeah and like 50 Cent left so
they're not gonna make any more power
shows God but I mean there is a literal
clock ticking which is that Keanu Reeves
is 58 yes and can he do single take
action scenes into his 16th or will he
want to even because like at a certain
point you do gotta go I would like to
still have knees in 20 years I don't
want to get hit by a car again I mean
please stop hitting me with cars that's
why you got the Continental show coming
out which is a prequel about Winston
arriving in New York you've got Anna De
armas they're hoping to do that
ballerina where she trains to be an
assassin movie so they're obviously
planning for a post Keanu Wick verse
well so should we talk about spoiler
alert the ending of the movie or
whatever yeah he's dead
but they gave him no face no case no
Facebook yes exactly
yeah there's a grave and we see Winston
in the Bowery King paying their respects
but you half expect that scene to end
with him like peeking out from a tree
yeah
so I don't think he's gone um I think
he's got at least one more uh way up
tier season like Lionsgate said they're
they're already thinking about what John
Wick 5 is going to be at the most recent
Earth and then I think you can continue
this world of just like John Wick is
more of a Vibe I mean even like just
introducing Donna Yen and I think other
action Stars will kind of want their
crack at this franchise maybe I don't
know if it's still called John Wick or
if John is more of like a Godfather
figure moving forward I don't know
there's options I hope it never ends
yeah I I think they could keep making
movies in that we all know even if you
take Keanu Reeves specifically out I
think John Wick movie we all still get
what that is you're you're in a
nightclub you're snapping a lot of
people's necks and shooting them in the
head there's neon everyone's still
dancing still dances like everybody's
around you are still dancing you pay for
everything with a gold coin you know
like there's someone like some Danish
guys like get him I I don't know what
David people say it's a very prissy guy
in a very fancy suit who's definitely
European is like waiting above watching
through like a
who has no sense of taste and that's
what makes him so dangerous
when that guy starts fighting yeah he's
lost his sense of taste you know he's
got all the other ones are heightened
yeah all right and then also just the
chef comes from the back and like they
start doing all their like yeah skills
with the knives and everything yeah
more to say about that later let's keep
going ended with John growling the word
yeah yeah
now pick up exactly where he left off
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
for another one action film that's once
again about trying to leave the Assassin
world because he clicked I agree without
reading the terms and conditions and at
the real ride that runs for just two
hours and 49 minutes because if your wit
goes hard for a full three hours you
have to seek medical attention also
everyone's wearing a vibranium suit this
time so it takes 10 shots to drop a
single goon
yeah plus I didn't like this escalation
of now everyone I guess this was always
the case but no it's they introduced
that in three the guys in the heavy
armor that he has to shoot you have to
shoot him in like the neck or you have
to shoot him like 10 times but even
still like anyone wearing a suit is
bulletproof now yeah yeah
it has like he gives him like a Kevlar
like suit suit which is like yeah can
you just not wear any other kind of
clothes like it's got to like look like
a business suit
he would look pretty dumb in like
motocross gear or something oh I just
watched cool as ice again so no so now
I'm here for it
it just gives these movies a different
vibe though like every other movie is
the heroes are always in like tactical
gear you know like that that militarized
like their Navy SEALS or John Halo yeah
and it's like and it's like I like that
that this one even though they treat it
like they're all in tactical gear
because they're all like they've all got
armor on yeah they just look like a
bunch of guys in suits like it gives it
a different aesthetic I guess it just
made John feel too bulletproof because
nine times in a in an action scene he's
it's also not like Kevlar with his
Blazer you can't get unlimited shots
into Kevlar I feel like it works once or
twice and then if you get shot like a
third time well they said it in the
third one is like yeah it'll stop a
bullet but it's gonna hurt like you are
not gonna be happy about that and he's
they're just pinging off him every he's
got high pain tolerance yeah I mean he
gets hurt a lot and he just kind of
walks it off yeah
um all right well that'll be a John Wick
chapter four Walk It Out keep going
John Wick is back and with every
assassin on his tail he can travel from
New York to Osaka to Berlin to Paris
without
incidents his next fighting game stage
oh boy
he's determined to let anything except
his words do the talking
probably because he's got CTE so bad he
can't string together a full sentence
that
oh he does that one on his own
endless dream a physical punishment and
personal criticism my father is dead
because of you because of you I had to
kneel in front of the man who murdered
my father but I didn't kill Koji you did
John just because of his never-ending
quest to kill everyone on planet Earth
no one not even you can kill everyone
Counterpoint yes he clearly can
yeah I understand this franchise like
the ending of
yeah what if they clone John Wick
that'll be trouble it's more than one
Wick two Wicks next time two weeks yeah
secret twin maybe yeah oh I love a
secret twin yeah
yeah also too Wiki by hooverphonic
that's your theme song
well it's just wiki wiki wild wild west
but just the first part yeah yeah
um the uh the ending of the one uh also
set to the dulcet tones of uh disturbs I
don't know what the actual song Down
With The Sickness
I think oh no is it it might be Papa
Roach it might be P roach if someone
fact checked me out yeah
um I feel like that was the first movie
too where a guy hit another guy with a
motorcycle which has now become like a
Trope like an rrr they do that and I
feel like a few other movies have not
done that but gently picks up a
motorcycle and like it's one of his
clones with it it's cool
and set his sights on the Marquee
another over matched Europe
we're watching the end of the one where
Jeffy has to kill all the other jellies
head wait is it
oh this is Paparazzi yeah all right glad
we crew that up okay keep playing
yet another overmatched European fancy
boy who you just know is evil because he
hangs out next to a skill model of a
city and only villains get to do that
John will also with his old friend Kane
and continue running up the scoreboard
against the hearing and Visually
Impaired Donnie Yen shines in another
blind roll because it would be straight
up unfair to let him fight if he could
actually see
they'll tangle with the tracker a guy
who's hunting John because he's too
broke to upgrade his phone watch and
dismay as he spends the film sniping
from the edge of the map like a [__]
camper
plus the real
I think if you pause and like really
read through his notebook he was just
trying to get a bunch of money for like
a nice house for his dog like that was
that was the way I read it it's like he
had like these scales of like millions
that he was looking for and then next to
it was a picture of like a cabin with a
dog it's not a cabin it's like a chalet
it's like a really nice house but yes
he's just saving up for his dream home I
feel like you don't need 50 million
euros for for a nice house in the Hills
but okay what do I know it's probably
also for like protection yeah well no
it's in Los Angeles yeah oh yeah well
yes everybody who lives in a nice house
in La has gone on a kill crazy uh
Rampage on behalf of the table that's
true Beyonce oh you don't want to know
he murdered a lot of people a lot of
people with a bat that's crazy
15 haters with that
um all right keep going
mcshane's Winston and recoil at the
debut of Ian mcshane's Winston's new
bleach tea
veneers or the tanning bed one of them's
got to go forget the characters this is
all about the action and man do they
deliver featuring some good
old-fashioned horseplay
the one that's just like my Japanese
animes
the one that confirms they turned off
car damage
thank you
where they're just playing Hotline Miami
the one where the stunt guys get to
really earn their paycheck
not on purpose to play the Assassin
version of Magic the Gatherings blades
understand how this game works
don't you guys have to like tap land
first or something it's always looked
way too boring to learn
after killing yeah
over the last three films watch jaw and
start to take his toll on the global
assassin industry forcing them to
inflate the wages the lottery just went
up higher poorly trained inexperienced
scabs
I think the the least realistic thing
about these movies is hearing that John
Wick is on the loose and trying to get
somewhere and grabbing a gun to go stop
him yeah I think anybody that's like oh
good this is a realizable goal for me
I'm a random guy right if you're a hit
man that's like shelter in place yeah
yeah bear kid it would be funny that's
one scene they haven't used yet in a
wick movie it's like an assassin getting
that message on his phone and be like
John Wick no thank you okay I will wait
too rich for my blood uh maybe common is
still around and I can take that guy out
but how come is dead on a subway I mean
he might have come back we don't see the
body he slumped he slumped yeah I feel
like you could still bring him yeah you
might be able to right on side you would
said it in your uh in your notes that
this had been all over a 72 hour period
I mean I was I was comically
exaggerating a little but only a little
bit the first three movies basically
were but then this one there's an
undisclosed amount of time
the hobo Dojo right yeah
we don't know exactly how long it's been
between three and four because he's been
in the Bowery King's Lair like Keeling
from him hanging out with Jason mandukas
yeah there's one yeah good job there's
always one role in a wick movie for a
guy who can't fight at all and that's a
case of manzuka's in three and then uh
like the camper guy he gets a couple
kills because you don't expect him to
have a gun I think just he's like he's
like slumped over it oh yeah no he does
yeah yeah he's playing yeah he takes it
he is an assassin he's just not a like a
great one he's like an okay one got it
he's a mid-level assassin all right keep
going
getting through their first shift alive
to the point where they're so desperate
for new hires they have to advertise on
FM radio
hit goes out to you
just awake come on now people we're
gonna have to do a lot better also enter
the code Warriors ripoff at checkout to
receive 20 off your next I mean that's
just like positive like that's I thought
that went beyond homage to me of like
the the Warriors it's a cult classic
like we all of course have seen a bunch
but uh to do like to call them Boppers
too it's like is this person just a huge
Warriors fan like in the universe
because they're just doing the exact or
they just really like visually and
dialogue yeah they like the hey gum
shoes lady like that's what it is like
gum shoes that would be good
you should just cut to the Acme cheese
you're like all right gum shoes We're
not far away from like an assassin uh
rockapella again John Wick is in a city
where they spend drachmas
the Relentless franchise that's got that
dog in it because now that you've seen
John Wick avenge a dog adopt a dog and
team up with a dog enjoy this new spin
where he fights a dog
then befriends a dog
that's because at the beginning they
killed his dog dog damn dog R.I.P to a
real one so pause
when did Lance Reddick die vis-a-vis
like production of this movie uh this
was already made it was already made so
it was just bad bad timing or yeah yeah
but they dedicated it to him which was
very sweet yes I believe the decision to
kill off his character preceding him
because it seemed like oh they did that
because let's read it no I don't think I
I think that was just a coincidence wow
what a crazy coincidence because it was
like yeah centered around his death yeah
I think they they killed his character
to raise the stakes not knowing that the
real man because he was his death was
sudden I don't believe he didn't have
like an extended sickness beforehand
right yeah well R.I.P man all right
also also in the new White Men Can't
Jump and his character also dies in that
movie which is weird wow yeah bummer
does he survive the wire
let's watch star
story
Ted Theodore Shogun Winston shakes out
Larry the table guy another Skarsgard
you're in your element Donnie it has
indeed it been an honor my friend now
fellas I want a clean duel I've got a
lot of money writing on this it's a
notebook get over here and have a
pleasant stay South American Ninja
Warrior the Atkins diet
and stay right back
[Music]
foreign
it's so weird that now it's just chapter
three it's called Parabellum
fun chapter 2 Parabellum chapter four
awesome
um really stands out they really really
needed that yeah so you know where where
you're at in the trash I'm sure that was
a Lionsgate Studio note and they're like
we know
we know better we're we're all you've
got we're just we're dropping names but
yeah that is the thing where it's like
that's why every sequel has dropped the
numbers and has a has a dumb you know
origins or uh Darkness or whatever
tagline is because people they just
found that more people go to see them if
they haven't seen the first one rather
than starting with number four or
something like yeah but not John Wick
you can walk in yeah
they're yeah it's like he's a killer
Everyone's an assassin in this world
they're all after him gum go Pew and go
yeah all right let's finish the little
tag
[Music]
you know he may think it's weird so many
people are still dancing but this is
actually the least disturbing thing that
happens in a German nightclub that's
right yeah yeah
um so start asking questions now and
we'll be ready for them by the time
these outtakes are over let's do that
story
Boogie fights Johnny Newman wig faulty
glowers Kill Bill you want to know how I
got these scars his job is Tables by Bob
is on the Swedish yen in Black John
stick now Kane I can get into one last
lands Fedora the Explorer you're a good
man Clancy Brown where my dogs at what
I do that before I walked in the room
dispossessed Hotel it's like one of my
Japanese animes StairMaster
top goon poker face
red table talk
Die Hard with a Vengeance
dual intentions
nice well as these are rolling in uh let
me just say thank you for watching and
check out the uh if John Wick were real
episode we just pushed out on this same
Channel people would be dead so many
people would be dead um a lawyer a
psychiatrist and uh on loan from
Gamespot their firearms expert to
analyze uh what he would pick from the
sommelier uh and you know if you should
kill someone with a library book or not
turns out you should because there's no
extra penalty for library books well
there you go so
um let's see let's uh these are coming
in fast now but let's start with uh Evan
Jay pretzeres I bought a lot of morb
juice and sent it to your office when it
comes can we all drink it again no I
will um we will all die take any more
more juice I've never touching that
again I was really honestly I'm not
joking it's not a bit I didn't feel good
for the rest
I know that would be a funny thing to
say even if I felt fine just to make fun
of morbius but no I swear I didn't feel
good for the rest of the day Anthony
Colton Jr asked do we have any ideas for
Wick five anything we'd like to see oh
fifth Wick uh fifth way I mean I I think
the the best thing they're doing is is
bringing in all of these International
martial artists like Marco's auror that
the south american guy who plays Chidi
yeah they never even said his name he's
cheating in the credits he was so cool
uh and obviously like guys like Donna
Yen like Scott Adkins uh it's so much
fun so that that's all I want I every
Wick movie should just be we we're gonna
find like six International badasses
like where's Tony ja bring him into this
also from Anthony Colton Jr what's our
favorite John Wick like film a film in
the in the vein of John Wick hmm I'm
thinking of those uh like the ray yeah I
was gonna say yeah
um it's called it comes at night the
night comes first that's right uh
there's also there there these are both
on Netflix uh they're they're the
original is called Fury f-u-r-i-e and
then there's a sequel Furies uh Veronica
no who's a I believe Vietnamese action
star she was in the Old Guard she's in
Last Jedi she stars in both of these she
directed the second one they're really
cool you know know what it's going to be
like a weird one and I I think they
actually might have taken it off the
platform which is kind of a bummer
um but Joey King did one called the
princess it just got pulled off of Hulu
which is basically just like if John
Wick was a captured Princess who had
secret weapons training yeah he was like
a fantasy princess who's got to marry
like a guy she doesn't love and she's
like escapes the castle and it's
basically just this is what's your
favorite Joan Wick film so that's it
there's also a really good Korean one
called the villainesse uh that that
actually that they did the uh like sword
fight on motorcycle bit first and then
week three kind of borrows it from them
uh so that's a really cool movie yeah a
couple people have asked this a great
zeticus uh also uh asked do we think
John is getting two superhero-ish now
like is this annoying or or distracting
that he's invulnerable and unkillable
and
as long as the fights are good that's
all I care about yeah I'm okay with him
it would be annoying if like he was
unkillable and the fights were like not
great but it's so good that I don't I
don't mind that yeah I think they
they're really good at doing the John
McLean with him which is like he
survives but it's not like he's
invulnerable he's getting his ass kicked
it's actually really brutal to be John
Wick and I think that gets you through
that it doesn't feel like he's
like Untouchable it just feels like he
survives FJ Prince are chiming in to say
he's just being silly he respects us too
much to put that pain on it yeah
um I think it's also molding uh the one
we have it got wet and now I I think
that that can't get it wet or consume it
actually yeah actually no don't do
either of those things that's actually
um people suggesting a uh an animated
John Wick series like an animatrix that
would be cool and uh John Wick having to
fight his way through hell to get to his
wife in heaven I like that there you go
a little fantasy version yeah why not
right and then we'll end with this Adam
Holbert asks um is it more or less
better to lose dialogue in an action
movie because Keanu insisted on removing
some of his lines to save on runtime
enough is to save on run time maybe it's
just like you don't need I don't need to
spell this out yeah people get it I'm
looking for Revenge it's like Nicholas
winning ref and famously went through
drive before like after they made it
drive had like Ryan Gosling's character
had normal movie dialogue and then when
they made the cut Nicholas Wendy Griffin
went out and like pulled almost all of
Ryan Gosling's dialogue he's like this
works better if you you don't need to
know that much about what's going on in
this guy's head and I almost feel like
that that was the right call like he's a
man of action you don't need to hear him
talking about what he's gonna do and I
think it's kind of the same for Wick
like we we know we know what he's gonna
do he's going to kill everyone yeah yeah
and I but I would much rather there be
less talking than if all of a sudden it
was it just got really stupid and jokey
yes I'm very glad that they don't he's
right behind me yeah
coin so so you know like I'm glad there
isn't yeah I'm thinking that just
happened
yeah I think the the few Reliance the
better exactly yeah we don't you don't
need it what what do we need to know
that we don't already know let the
bodies do the talking so uh next week
well we're going back to the future not
back to the future but it is a Past film
about a future we'd all like to live in
I think yeah um I would we'd be with our
best friends and I've always wanted this
kind of best friend yeah exactly always
exactly
um so we're about to get trucked up next
week on us trailers we hope you'll join
us then on Australia commentary same
time same place thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you